you guys ever had like a food product
like later in life
that you just like couldn't believe that
you'd
waited this long in life before you had
this one food product
because i'll tell you what i was gonna
say you must have a very small yeah
i mean because thinking about it you
have this super specific situation
did you have this super specific
situation
because i'll tell you mine actually um
because i didn't try nutella for the
first time until i was 24.
how did you avoid nutella okay because
that's
everywhere yeah because i was a kid i
wasn't allowed nutella right because my
parents wouldn't let in that yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
cause cause it's basically just [ __ ]
chocolate right it's just basically
chocolate it's actually worse for you
than chocolate
yeah yeah that's understandable yeah so
i just went my entire life without
trying
without trying nutella i don't know how
but like how how has nutella been
branded as just like this thing you can
spread on toast and people eat for
breakfast
right and that feels like a cheat code
to me you know because i remember trying
it for the first time and i'm just like
this is the most amazing snack i've i've
ever tried in my life
it's just like the [ __ ] gates of
babylon opened i'm just like
oh my god i've i have discovered gods
it literally goes on like everything
yeah i know i can open the jar and just
start
the glory my favorite thing is like this
like
oh god i cover which one youtube video
is called again i forget the song
but there's literally a video where uh
they were like
uh it was about this whole the deception
of nutella being a breakfast product
yeah
and there was this part in it where they
go around the parents who are feeding
their kids in nutella and they're like
do you know how much sugar is in nutella
they're like
no and they tell them they're like
there's a lot of sugar like a lot yeah
like
oh my god i had no idea and they're like
they look like so dumbfounded
like what are you serious the chocolate
spread
the pure 100 chocolate flavor that i'm
spreading on a piece of bread twice
is bad for myself you're kidding me it's
just like i'm surprised surprise pikachu
face
oh my god i've been feeding my kid
chocolate this whole time it's like
what did you think it was no one thought
it wasn't chocolate we all know that
nutella is chocolate just because it's
like kind of liquidy like very viscous
you think it just gets a pass yeah why
yeah why is that nutella as a passing
yeah cocoa puffs is like no no no no no
it's a branding joey branding is
powerful
like like how did how did we how did
they get away with this for so long i
don't know
nutella [ __ ] slaps but i i knew as
soon as i tasted it it's [ __ ]
unhealthy as [ __ ] oh yeah um but it
takes amazing
literally anyone who who knows what
sugar tastes like could be like i think
this is
this is pretty bad that's pretty bad
yeah pretty bad for years i think
actually you know
because my parents would only let me
have it on uh holidays
that's how like taboo it was it was like
this is special occasions no i think my
parents let me have nutella
like pretty much every morning if i
wanted it but then i very quickly was
like
this is too much like there's too much
sugar even for like my eight-year-old
body i know this is too much sugar
like i'm just like i like i'm just like
as a now i just think
kids you're not allowed to have ice
cream for breakfast but nutella that's
okay yeah i'm just like to me they're
they're on the same [ __ ] level you
should put nutella on ice cream
that sounds amazing nutella flavored
gelato nutella on some like [ __ ]
vanilla ice cream
i should slap i mean that's it's just a
dessert right i mean it is yes
it's just chocolate it's literally just
chocolate
just a bit it's just a bit of a nutty
chocolate right it's ridiculous you know
what's another thing i [ __ ] grab i
think i just like
grew out of like all like viscous
breakfast spreads
biscuits breakfast oh yes what's your
favorite
what's your favorite viscous breakfast
spread
i'm pretty sure that's the first time in
the history of man that those three
words have been put in the same sentence
together
this is like alien alien alien to the
best of your knowledge describe what
this spread is i do
love this viscous breakfast red cumin
i specifically use the word viscous
because like yeah i could feel someone
doing the [ __ ] lawnmower
in his [ __ ] head trying to form that
sentence because okay i i use the word
viscous because like
jam for instance i know you can talk
about peanut butter and jelly
no no no that's her but like jam for
instance right
that's not viscous you know what i mean
it depends you can make it
it doesn't it doesn't stick to the roof
of your mouth like
nutella does all right i love a good
[ __ ] jam but the thing is it's like
not only did i like grow out of nutella
but also like peanut butter i used to
[ __ ]
love peanuts i don't know a single
person in the uk who ate peanut butter
as a child
right but like no no i didn't eat peanut
butter really
yeah because i ate it as a child but
then after a while i was like
i i don't know i don't think i like this
just
the fact that every time i take a bite
and it just feels like i just
swallowed a mouthful of glue it's just
like honestly it's viscous the viscous
this is the viscosity of peanut butter
that i don't like
nine out of ten people i know who have
peanut butter is just for catching mice
that's why i had it really yeah i i only
bought it because apparently mice
[ __ ] love it
don't well yeah i don't blame them i
mean i'm i'm licking the floor so i mean
it caught me i got god damn i got my
tongue
i'm just ready for the drake meme like
peanut butter and jelly sandwich
i sleep like viscous breakfast spread
real [ __ ] no yeah i
i remember like because i hadn't tried
peanut but that was another
food item that i didn't try until later
in life was peanut butter i've never had
just peanut butter on like a sandwich or
something yeah and i remember trying it
for the first time and i was
very underwhelmed by it it was like the
most
five out of ten food item i've ever like
tasted in my life
what about its viscosity doesn't that
[ __ ] just like stick to your mouth
okay do you do you okay which which kind
of spreads did you have did you have
like the chunky spread or did you have
like the smooth spread
uh i mean i went either all right i've
never had a spread of peanut butter
you've never had a spread of peanut
butter never had reese's cupcakes which
i i you know i wasn't i also hate the
viscosity of those well i remember
the first time we just want to say
wisconsin i
very much had like the kombucha teami
moment when i first tried the reese's
cupcakes
right and i was like i had it i was like
oh
i think the one thing i don't like about
reese's cups is that again it's the
peanut butter it just overpowers
everything and it's like a certain this
is the point i don't know if that's the
point i don't know if that's there's
like something about the peanut butter
that i just
don't like peanut butter foreigners try
and figure out american food yeah
what is going on